لسنوات ، كان أخصائيو التغذية
يروجون للآثار الإيجابية لنظام
البحر الأبيض المتوسط
ليء بالخضار والفواكه وحبوب ال
مك وزيت الزيتون وقليلة الدهون ، ح
ث تم وضع النظام الغذائي للوقاية من مش
كل القلب والأوعية الدموية وخ
ض ضغط الدم ، وق
يقلل النظام الغذائي المتوسطي من خطر ال
عاناة من مناطق صغيرة  من تلف الدماغ
المسمى احتشاءات والذي يسبب مشاكل في التفكير ،
نظر باحثو جامعة كولومبيا
إلى ما يزيد قليلاً عن 700 من سكان نيويورك
ووضعوهم في ثلاث مجموعات بناءً على
مدى
قربهم من اتباع نظام البحر الأبيض المتوسط الغذائي ، حي
تم إعطاء كل منهم صورة من الدماغ بعد ست سن
ات ، وأظهر الفحص أن  يعاني أكثر من
الثلث بقليل من منطقة واحدة على الأقل
من تلف الدماغ ، ووجدوا أيضًا أن
أولئك الذين كانوا يتبعون
حمية البحر الأبيض المتوسط عن كثب كا
وا أقل عرضة بنسبة 36 في المائة للإصابة بم
اطق تلف في الدماغ من
ولئك الذين لم يتبعوا ال
ظام الغذائي الأشخاص الذين اتبعوا ال
ظام الغذائي بشكل معتدل  كانوا أقل عرضة بنسبة 21 في المائة
للإصابة بتلف في الدماغ مقارنة بأدنى
مجموعة بحث سابق من قبل هؤلاء
أظهر العلماء
أن النظام الغذائي على طراز البحر الأبيض المتوسط قد يكون مر
بطًا بانخفاض خطر الإصابة بمرض ال
هايمر وقد يطيل البقاء على قيد الحياة لدى الأشخاص المصابين بم
ض الزهايمر من خل
ل هذه الدراسة الأخيرة ، فقد يكونون أق
ب إلى فهم سب
هذه اللحظة الصحية أنا سوزان هن
ريكس